other conservative MP and chair of the
women and equalities committee Caroline
Knox joins us now morning see you this
morning
um I mean the the headline figure in
this report the black women are four
times more likely to die in these
circumstances than white women is bad
enough just take us through the findings
of the report before we move on to the
the conclusions well it's very Stark
that a black mother is 3.7 times more
likely to die than a white one an Asian
mother 1.8 times
um and that in itself is horrendous we
know that maternity services in this
country by and large are safe and that
you're unlikely to die but this
disparity is really Stark and really
long-standing we've known about it for
20 years so the committee is calling
upon the government to actually focus in
on this take action don't assume because
maternity services are safe that they're
safe for everyone there is a difference
tackle it do we understand what what the
root cause of this disparity is because
uh speaking Titanic a little bit earlier
on I mean clearly she said racism is a
part of this but it is not everything of
course oh and it's very complex and it
would be fair to say if you would talk
to a professor Marion Knight she would
always make the point this is a really
complicated multi-faceted problem but
it's about structural inequalities it's
about poor housing it's about poor
education it's about the way women are
being treated when they arrive in the
labor Ward the way that they are being
ignored that their concerns are being
disregarded and if you talk to five
times more and I know you have they will
always make the point that they felt
that the women who they survey felt
ignored they felt that when they said
something is going wrong with my body
that it was just dismissed and they were
told you know go home you're fine you're
not in labor yet and I think that's what
really concerns me is that we must make
sure that women are treated in a
culturally appropriate way that we
recognize that there is this disparity
and so start taking the steps around
training around making sure that there's
enough funding for continuity of carer
and recognizing that the people living
in the most deprived communities are
most likely to have the worst outcomes
in maternity does does this research
suggest that there needs to be an
attitudinal shift amongst at least some
staff working in maternity units look I
think it very clearly highlights that
that there is an attitudinal problem in
some instances and I'm not saying that
everybody in the NHS is racist far from
it but I'm saying look the Department of
Health the Royal College of Hobson gyne
the national Midwifery Council need to
all come together and focus in on this
is a specific problem how can we make
sure that any hint of racism is drummed
out of rnhs and that it's a service that
is equal for everybody and will treat
everybody's concerns equally yeah I mean
actually Nikki was describing her own
personal experience and and ideas such
as you know the black women are somehow
able to to come out cope with pain that
black women are somehow you know louder
or more boisterous and need to be put in
their place I mean it strikes me that if
you have people who genuinely believe
things like their working maternity was
that there's not an awful lot you can do
to shift the attitude of someone like
that and that was the evidence that five
times more gave to the committee and it
was really compelling and heartbreaking
to hear the stories of women who had
been told exactly that you don't feel
pain the same way course they feel pain
the same way of course they need to be
listened to and supported and this is
why our NHS needs to have culturally
competent trainees why we need to have
diversity and inclusion uh members of
Staff working in the NHS so women like
Chloe and Technical five times more are
listened to and that acted upon their
concerns to make sure this doesn't keep
happening we can't be back here in 20
years saying oh well you know it shifted
a tiny bit we need it to be parity and
as we were discussing just in the break
there sometimes the experiences that
women have in maternity was when they
are not uniformly positive that that
does happen with white women as well as
well as with black women too it really
does and poor experiences immaternity
can live with women for the rest of
their lives and it will impact the
number of children that they go on to
have and so although we know giving
birth in this country is safe we know
that we have a phenomenally low levels
of maternal morbidity the start reality
is is that we have to address the
disparity team we have to make sure that
we do better what noises are you healing
from inside Doh inside from inside
government that they are taking this
problem seriously as you say I mean we
have known about this for an awfully
long time so there's a real problem with
data collection and Maria Caulfield when
she came in front of the committee the
tail end of last year was really candid
and really constructive with us and made
the point that we need to do better
about understanding which interventions
work look there's a massive delay around
collection of data and the confidential
inquiry that looks at all maternal
deaths sometimes there'll be a 500 day
delay between a death happening and them
getting the information which makes it
really hard to assess it accurately and
understand what the root causes were so
I want the dhsc to focus in on that and
work out how all the bodies like the
office for National statistics can work
better to get data quicker I think that
matters but it's also about using the
maternity disparities task force which
was set up last year hasn't met for a
while is scheduled to meet again very
imminently and using that as a way to
bring in new strategy and really Drive
change I I think it's probably worth our
home is not just if we reiterate a point
that you have made several times because
there may well be people who are
pregnant who are about to head into
Maternity Ward right now who are
watching this and feeling worried in
general we do pretty well in terms of
Maternity in this country don't we yeah
we do we do we have a very low rate of
maternal morbidity low rate of
stillbirths what we're focusing on is
the disparity here and so my message to
women is you are safe but also it's
really important that going into this
experience that women feel confident
enough to use their own voices and to
use their partners for support and make
sure that when they feel things are
going wrong that they're not afraid to
speak out exactly that Caroline knows
good to see you this morning thanks been
with us